le tente est une maison c'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir un appartement et
j'ai planté le tente en 2009 sur un
terrain de golf à tied 7 hectares de
terre pour moi entouré par la ville
urbaine de le Banu parisien et je suis
resté 3 ans là-bas pendant que j'ai
continué de donner des cours de business
et tout j'ai fait des feux de bois et
bon ça veut dire que tu étais à l' fois
prof en même temps tu vivais ouais d' et
bon j'étais le prof de les gens très
haut dans la
société c'est pas une question de moyens
finalement tu avais les moyens d'avoir
oui j'avais les moyens mais bon c'est
oui c'était bien de mettre l'argent à
côté aussi pour mon décrépitude quand je
suis
décrépi quand j'ai S2 ans j'espère que
j'aurais quelques milliers d'euros dans
la banque pour acheter une Yar
quelque
[Musique]
chose